i go in and he's like i like poured a
cup of tea because that's what we do in
england if you
graduate from college you get a cup of
tea if your cat dies let's have a cup of
tea if you moon your maths teacher and
are about to get suspended we have a cup
of tea all right gq what's up i'm
youngblood i'm gonna go undercover on
the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
nah man it's me for real i promise you
ready
you slash mk six ria
i didn't know exclamation mark i'm a new
father youngblood after like three hours
of interviews i find out dom was on
disney channel in the uk yeah man i was
i was in bed with mickey mouse for a bit
and then he found out i was a bit
[ __ ] naughty so
fruity tooty dual pods
what's your favorite song of the album
in such an honor question because like
saying which one you like your kids you
prefer i don't even have kids but today
it would probably be
mars
because that song's super important to
me wikipedia
harrison sites rock pop and hip hop
artists such as arctic monkeys the
beatles the cure robert smith nevana the
clash sound guard and my comical romance
lady gaga lord post malone kanye west
and eminem as influencers you pretty
summed that up like well it's basically
just an orgy of all those artists just
imagine like a massive orgy of those
artists and then that's youngblood and
i'm just like there you go i mean like
pouring the drinks and opening the
condoms on may 30th 2020 youngblood
attended the george floyd protester
black lives matter in california heaton
halls you helped give first aid some of
the protesters that was probably one of
the most
shocking and
incredible experiences of my life all at
the same time the atrocity that was
committed
was just so devastating but the way
everyone came together simply for what
was right it was so incredible to be
there we have still got such a long way
to go
um but yeah it was it was
incredible to see the amount of people
from
from all races all shapes all sizes
fighting for what was right harrison was
diagnosed with adhd at a young age it
made him a troublesome student he was
suspended from school after a dare from
his friend to moon his math teacher and
we make jacob spooner all right spooner
if you're watching this was just like
days to get your ass out to miss ammo
and then another person was like i dare
you and then another person another
person which kind of turned into a
little bit of a chant i didn't think
she'd see me
until i got it out i got my arse out
right and i pressed it against the glass
i remember me running off and then
thinking i'd like kind of got away with
it the deputy head comes into the
classroom and goes
you know who you are and i was just like
[ __ ] and he's laughing
while he's like you can't be oh you
can't be doing this in the real world
like laughing and i'm like sir you're
laughing at me and then that was it and
then i had a week off school
reflecting on my actions
and i can confirm i've never moved a
math teacher
since
quora
the [ __ ] quora
is youngwood goth emo or what i am who i
am i don't [ __ ] know some days i
think i'm a strawberry what do you
admire most about youngblood
i smile a lot
what can you tell me about youngblood
that wikipedia can't i'm really really
really [ __ ] good at making popcorn
just come around to my house movie night
how should we dress for a young blood
concert however you want to dress if you
want to come
in
skinny jeans coin skinny jeans if you
want to wear a chicken suit wear a
chicken suit if you want to steal your
dad's dress
[ __ ] bring your dad's dress
or your mum's dress whatever you want
you are welcome here i promise you just
youngwood like football bracket premier
league close bracket question i'm more
of a second division kind of guy to be
honest no i i am i like don casterova's
all leads united depending on which side
of the family you're talking sir which
thing huh would you like most to be
stuck on a desert island with liam
gallagher
because i [ __ ] love him
period
twitter at youngblood what hair color do
you use is it manic panic directions or
which one it's the blood of my enemies
i'm joking depends what i can get my
hands on to be honest blood of my
enemies what a knob
at black hearts lily answer what do you
call this young blood most importantly
what do you call it where i'm from it's
called a batch i don't know where to
[ __ ] you're from because i've never seen
that called a batch it's called a bap a
bap a b.a.p a breakfast bap
[ __ ]
sausage bap
[ __ ] cheese bap
strawberry bap if you're weird [ __ ]
bat
dom's been so quiet i'm pretty sure he's
plotting something youngblood what have
you got planned
a lot full stop like i don't think i
have any idea man it's all gonna be
[ __ ]
cool and fun and nice
youtube
parents official music video so nobody's
gonna ask why his best friend was just
chilling in his garden because i was
getting ready to [ __ ] him silly
what is this song meaning i want to know
before i tell my guests
since the beginning of my career all i
wanted to do was to build a community
where people could be themselves
that's it like
i didn't i didn't really give a [ __ ]
about
how well my songs did or whatever all i
cared about was just
making sure that we had a culture that
we could kind of exist in like happily
and peacefully making people feel like
they could be who they are
and i was in maryland
and
a young trans girl came up to me and she
said to me that
her parents couldn't understand
that she wasn't always in like in fact
had been a girl
she said that
all she could think about was getting
her parents to a younger girl not to see
me not to like for any other reason and
she wanted them to see the community and
the culture
that we had because
it would make them
realize that she wasn't some freak or
doing it for attention she was
this person and she was valid and she
was real and she was heard and she saved
up her money she
she got good grades and and the parents
came and
after the gig they saw
this culture this community
all the kids like her and it like they
accepted her as their baby girl and
i just [ __ ] me up man i was like
what like
and that's what i always
dreamed that this would do for people
this is not about anything other than
resonating the idea that you can be
yourself so that's that i think it's
probably
the most important song i've ever earned
guys hear me out mgk young with travis
parker former fan what would their name
be [ __ ] we always we we said this
i can't remember
it would have to be naughty it would
have to be loud and energetic it'd have
to be in all caps
spank in all caps
all right man i'm gonna see spanx
tonight they're sick they will
definitely not agree with me on this by
the way so it's what i want it to be
tick tock do you feel comfortable with
people calling you dominic no that's
what my mom calls me and i'm naughty i'm
pansexual i'm having a hard time coming
out
to people most of my parents can give me
some advice please sexuality and
expression of sexuality such a hard
thing because the idea that everyone has
a perception of who you are and doesn't
truly know you your whole life is so
[ __ ] frightening and i think kind of
when you say yo all right what's up this
is who i am and people don't understand
it people it was my biggest fear it was
my biggest fear to be like i've been
living a little bit of a lie my whole
life and if you can't love me and
support me for who i am i think it's
going to be the last straw but i just
want to say to you out there don't be
nervous because even if your parents
don't understand we will we're here for
you and and we will make them understand
you know what i'm saying i think that
the way we make them understand is with
our voices and coming together i wish
you all free happiness
all right that's it i'm signing off the
internet thank you so much i'll see you
on tour
love ya